de la croatie le lac eu un choc de la
cus est très chargé où poser des
questions vous allez devoir lever la
main avant de répondre vous allez devoir
boire un des chocs que vous avez devant
vous d'accord la question il vous buvez
le choc numéro en question de choc
numéro 2 etc
vous allez voir dans certains il ya des
très bonnes choses allaient qui fait et
dans d'autres c'est moins bien
il n'y a pas d'alcool bien entendu et
bien sûr l'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé a chaté bien sûr à boire à
consommer avec attention aux premières
questions première question il en dira
qu a déclaré kobi noise heroes
l'interprète de capitaine marleau je
n'ai jamais voté de ma vie si macron
c'est un pote à toi tu peux t'en aller
j'ai une grande gueule et je la termine
jamais où je connais mimie mathy depuis
tout petit qu'elle brûle
alors il faut boire faut boire ça sert à
rien de temps michel castillon de mâcon
c'est un pote à toi tu peux t'en avais
n'était pas bon des galas et dégueulasse
mais bravo vous avez gagné un point
alors depuis quelques jours on ne parle
que d'eux que sa machine bah qu'est ce
que je t'aime
ces moines âge de ville le vinaigre
c'est pas la petite bête projet d'accord
s'il vous plaît sur son scalp depuis
quelques jours donc on parle de beaucoup
beaucoup de corinne bazire est donc la
prochaine marlou qu'ils non seulement
pour ses scores d'audience
exceptionnelle chez yoplait mais aussi
pour ses propos sur emmanuel macron qui
ont fait réagir regarder on vous
explique tout ça et c'est vrai qu'elle a
cartonné capitaine mario 7,7 millions de
téléspectateurs encore bas l'arrière
arrière garde c'est parti dans cette
période de crise que traverse la france
rares sont ceux qui soutiennent
officiellement le président et sa
politique dans les médias et ce n'est
pas cette nouvelle sortie qui va changer
la donne lors d'un reportage corinne
masiero l'actrice qui incarne la très
populaire capitaine marleau n'a pas
hésité à se lâcher en évoquant emmanuel
macron encore garalo jean sérien
chapeaute à toi si sa peau tu as toi tu
peux t'en aller saluer et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle ne semble
pas porter le président dans son coeur
engagée et militante elle avait refusé
il ya peu de se rendre à l'elysée alors
qu'elles y étaient invités pour assister
à la projection des invisibles
un film sur le quotidien des femmes sdf
dans lequel elle avait tourné
[Musique]
alors sur twitter d'un producteur de
spectacles jean marc dumontet qui a tenu
à réagir après les déclarations de
corinne à 0 on a le droit d'être en
désaccord avec emmanuel macron aussi le
devoir de la courtoisie en démocratie on
peut équiper les son époux son
opposition la civilité fait toujours du
bien moi je vais donner mon avis voilà
après ce que vous allez voir on va ré
écouter les propos donc de corinne
masero tur emmanuel macron qui ont
beaucoup fait réagir
moi je vous dis la vérité moi je pense
qu'on a besoin de personnages comme ça
on n'en peut plus moi j'en peux plus des
mecs qui disent rien et voilà qu'ils
disent jamais rien sur personne ne se
donne jamais leur a dit le contexte
oui mais bon on regarde et après on en
parle on regarde et on parle aux gens
c'est rien c'est un pote à toi si c'est
un poteau tu peux t'on allez salut voila
alors j'ai joué là-dessus absolument
aucun problème elle a le droit de dire
ce qu'elle pense voilà c'est fait d'air
frais en revanche effectivement quand
elle va à l'elysée pour présenter son
film et connaît le snobe le couple
présidentiel même brigitte mâcon qui n'y
est pour rien je trouve que c'est un peu
trop voilà ma parcelle revendique elle
revendique son côté et elle le dit
elle-même d'une famille de prolos de
communistes elle le dit elle la sauce et
qu'elle n'aurait pas dû aller à l'elysée
non voilà voilà ni bayonne c'est ça qui
va passer dans ses comptes
blanchard dignac a refusé de révéler une
décoration à la dijon veut pas voilà
bien équitable
je m'appelle moi c'est plus la tacc
entre guillemets sur la fonction qui me
gêne si macron c'est un pote à toi je
trouve que ès qualité c'est le président
de la république quoi qu'on en pense
je n'aime pas trop qu'on en parle comme
ça je fais pas de politique c'est le
real a fonctionné bien sûr après un
petit baiser
oliva ya des bonjour à tout le monde où
il vient pas alors oui alors françois
hague a réellement eu peur toute l'année
dernière parce qu'elles modifient
tellement les dialogues pardon soit
françois roy françois modifie tellement
les dialogues la chaîne a peur que ça
finisse par la couper d'une partie du
public mais et que messi et josé
l'alliance à la gonfle un peu aussi pas
mal à cause de ça j'adore ma chérie mais
on sait pas du tout le sujet là messi
donne ton avis je suis l'ami en question
sinon après parce qu'elle politiste où
il ça finit par être gênant surtout en
période électorale
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que ça
participe à la halle comment dirais-je à
nos propres qu'on jette sur les médias
un journaliste pose une question tu n'as
pas lui dire tu aimes pas ma compta
qu'attend à l'effet moi je n'aime pas du
tout lorsqu'on jette justement les
journalistes il ya aussi le respect de
la fonction du jour
liste après ma propre je vous dis et
voilà c'est vrai qu'on peut ça peut être
discutable mais moi j'aime les
personnages comme ça je pense qu'on en a
besoin au plus moi des mecs consensuel
qui n'a rien n'à jamais le radium
mais la face dit s'est passé là-bas on
peut l après elle a pas de mots sales de
mauvais moments difficiles mais bon
c'est vrai qu'on peut ne pas parler du
prix donc à bien ce programme est là pas
dire j'ai trouvé que c'était plutôt de
laval et terrebonne journal a choisi en
tout cas à l'aller les ai pas serrer la
main à mâcon ça c'est si l'on n'y va pas
tu vas pas reçu les lits et qu'après il
expliqué mission ouais mais ça prend les
appels à renoncer mais c'est quand même
super consensuel d'aller à l'encontre du
président et de dire ce qu'elle dit
alors moi je veux bien ouais franchement
un peu dans le sens du vent j'ai excusez
moi juste pour savoir m ils vous
attendent
la natation synchronisée vous la faites
à quelle heure on a l'impression qu'elle
dorme balle à la poitrine ou ça passe
sur le service public et par la
redevance et que c'est quand même
quelque chose nationale et je suis comme
vous ne l'avez vous pas aller plus loin
oui le film est subventionnée mais oui
bien sûr ce n'est par l'état donc alors
on à l'elysée je vous dit tout géraldine
et c'est pour ça que j'aime aussi
géraldine elle est très bonne élève
non mais siri géraldine c'est vraiment
non mais c'est vrai oui c'est pour ça
que je vous aime aussi
mais voilà vous ça vous dérange voilà
les jeux vous avez refusé par respect
pour la fonction j'ai l'impression pour
les oui mais en revanche j'adore mois sa
prise de position ça ne me dérange pas
voilà comme joker j'ai aucun souci avec
ça va je trouve qu'au contraire comme
vous je pense qu'aujourd'hui le dialogue
est un peu aseptisé jouines voile
sportive c'est vrai les corps rien et ça
fait du bien quand il ya des gens qui
jouent un peu on n'en peut plus les mecs
veulent rien dire sur personnes allaient
qui qu'a dit johnny guillaume canet pour
son anniversaire en 2017
j'adorerais tourner dans la suite des
petits pochoir après ce que tu aimes
seul dieu peut juger rock'n'roll is dead
mais c'est des conneries tout ça le
rock'n'roll n'est pas mort ou si tu lis
pour la musique la musique te le rendra
toujours qu'est ce qu'il a dit à lévis
rock'n roll is dead mais c'est des
conneries tout ça le rock n roll n'est
pas mort à vos jeux
bon là sport alors hier guillaume canet
fêter ses 46 ans pour l'occasion
laetitia lui a souhaité à sa façon un
joyeux anniversaire
elle a dévoilé une vidéo de johnny s'est
d'ailleurs pas la première fois qu'elle
fait ça et il ya encore des gens qui ont
été un petit peu énervé voilà quelle
sorte une vidéo de johnny moi je trouve
que c'est un bel hommage à guillaume
khalifa et nous dire ce que vous en
pensez
regardez le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que laeticia hallyday sait faire
parler d'elle hier à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire de l'acteur guillaume
canet la veuve du taulier a posté sur
instagram une vidéo encore jamais vu de
son défunt mari une vidéo dans laquelle
le rockeur rejoue une réplique du film
rock'n'roll dans lequel il interprétait
son propre rôle sorti en 2010 est si
certains fans de la star et autres
follower de laëtitia ont tout de suite
été enchantés de découvrir ces images
d'autres ont peu apprécié que la femme
du chanteur se permet d'utiliser l'image
de johnny comme elle l'entend et fasse
parler la star décédée sur instagram
une chose est sûr en pleine tourmente
autour de l'héritage les moindres faits
et gestes de la veuve du chanteur sont
épiés et interprétée
alors mes z'amis pas franchement son
côté mais là on peut pas lui reprocher
bah ouais c'est une vidéo là faut pas
charrier comme le sélectionneur n'y a
rien de grave là dessus voilà alors
route sur lequel tu as quelque chose à
dire on tient compte non non ça personne
mais dans la déclaration d'amour c'était
hyper gênant mais l'aca barack obama est
il assez cool franchement c'est des
images du rockeur qu'on a envie de mai
elle se bat comme un petit fou de vidéos
comme ça elle en a fait une gaffe a
encore plus parler ou la poster une
vidéo avec l'ex de laura ce qu'elle
invitait à saint barth et c est la
sarthe du coup ça a rendu complètement
des carnicas récemment marion
maréchal-le pen
un jour alors su souplesse et une en
avant voire et on attend un jour je
serai présidente inch'allah notre
démocratie est devenue une à nous de
nacre à 6 emmanuel macron devrait
démissionner ou je suis en couple avec
faudel qu'a dit kadhi marion marie
vierge de votre main vous l'avez vu trop
tôt la bulle
[Applaudissements]
il adore il aille mais en plus elles
avaient applaudi a déclaré que notre
démocratie est devenue une démocratie et
pour que tu prends comme ça
le bois du bal comme ça alors que sa
devise c'est vrai à la librairie
interview magazine valeurs actuelles qui
lui consacre dix pages dans son nouveau
numéro
elle a parlé politique bien sûr et
d'après elle la démocratie dans laquelle
on vit ça s'appelle pas vraiment
démocratie c'est pas pour moi oui mal de
moi c'est pas compris japonais je le
connais pas je suis pas de changement
envie de la connaître et la nes de
marine le pen donc à donner son avis sur
ce qui était devenu la france et elle
m'a taclé bon voilà je leur ai demandé
bah voilà marion maréchal-le pen y fait
rapport avec marlène schiappa mais que
les politiques se mêlent aux masses dans
les médias etc
kim connivence elles viennent le dire
ici qu'il vienne me dire l a4 mire et le
dire ici
regardez marion maréchal-le pen est de
retour dans les médias après un an de
silence suite à son retrait de la vie
politique pourtant la nièce de marine le
pen affiliés rassemblement national ne
semble pas tout à fait avoir accroché
avec l'actualité et la politique
dans une longue interview accordée à
valeurs actuelles elle livre sa vision
de la france est aimé de fortes
critiques sur emmanuel macron pourrait
le pays serait devenu aujourd'hui une
hanouna cratie une référence appuyée aux
différents responsables politiques qui à
l'instar de marlène schiappa ont choisi
balances ton post ces derniers mois pour
s'exprimer à la télévision notre
démocratie est devenue une hanouna
cratie décidément au rassemblement
national le changement semble être
encore une fois quelque chose qui a du
mal à passer
oui je sais que vous n'aimez pas les
tricheurs tiens à dire quand même que
maxime avec son petit air four e au lieu
de prendre le 3 il savait que le 2 était
bon il a redit dur alors je vais vous
dire ça va être essentielle posée la
question qu'elle lui sur la prochaine
merci jean michel c'est toute sa passion
maréchal le pen aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle fait et on
s'en fout complètement
mais un jour elle a voulu représenter le
peuple est là le méprise totalement
disant ça veut dire quoi centre aimerait
ça veut dire que ici des gens qui
veulent s'exprimer
à ses yeux n'ont pas de valeur n'ont pas
le droit c'est ridicule grotesque pour
une ex fâcheux pour ce cadeau qu'on l'a
vite
non mais sabah ne l'invité pas le mérite
elle ne vous mérite pas oh non non mais
que maintenant les gens faire le dise le
moana il veut faire du buzz et là elle a
une petite équipe de com ils sont dix
anacacis huppert terme comme ça ça va
être pris ça va faire du buzz non elle
se servira pas de vous pour faire du
buzz je suis d entendre moi c'est une
consécration non ce mr merci oui je
pense que j'ai rachida dati fait d'avoir
mis hanouna cratie je trouve que c'est
que c'est le symbole même de la réussite
de l'émission d'anesthésiant nouvelle
émission pour une nouvelle émission où
le débat se passe aujourd'hui j'ai
hanouna et c'est un compliment pour tout
à fait mature
[Applaudissements]
ça valait que pour toi tu as déclaré
sophie davant à propos de l'éventuelle
disparition de l'émission c'est au
programme
france télé une belle bande de tarder à
on va faire des changements il faut
arrêter où je vais me battre
c'est une faillite tu vois il n'a pas
pris des mois suis là je n'ai pas
celui-là comme un gars tu la gardes tu
la mets l'hôtel haute à côté il va
mourir lambert alors les blessures tout
d'abord elle va se battre pour sauver
c'est au programme
est ce que va traverser ce point bas
serait à mon avis oui ça coûte
m nos discussions na s'est consolé le
feuilleton coup de bêche moins cher
millions d'euros d'économies par an eh
ben ils coupaient là où c'est possible
des banques eba très bien la serre
conclu l amérique